hello and welcome to the talk on
next-generation cancer care in the age
of genomics precision medicine and
hydrobiology my name is Gillian Lynne no
be sort of talking through this my
background is when my training was in a
yield and did my MBP she at Hopkins and
has done work at Wash U looking at
implementing cancer genomics and now the
founder president for genomics Institute
so to talk a little bit about this I'm
told to remind people that if people
have questions to feel free to put them
in the Q&A section and as we go along
and we will unmask in them at the end
great so in order to the first serve
Taco Bell sort of cancer Jeff Kerr and
cancer genomics we really have to really
start at the beginning what is cancer
and and what why is it that way thinking
about genomics in cancer genomics the
first started off with a seminal paper
I'm really in 1990 by a career on and
portfolio scene looking at a genetic
model for cancer tumor Genesis and what
the fundamental sort of finding in this
paper that the outline is in cancer
ultimately there's a genetic disease
this was actually a very fundamental and
foundational understanding that cancer
is not you know some sort of infectious
disease or something that's sort of
other causes but fundamentally it is a
disease of genes there are other things
that can affect the gene but ultimately
it's the genes it's important and that's
why if genes are important that genomics
would be important and that's really
starting off the field of cancer
genomics so historically there has been
understanding of cancer histologic
internal histopathology in the different
states starting off with Sir
hyperproliferation too small so polyps
this specifically between a colorectal
cancer and it is severe dysplasia and
Nova and Carly the cancer and what this
paper in 1990 really was able to connect
is providing a genetic mark genetic
model for each of these steps at each of
these stages then linking what's
observed in terms of the histopathology
to genetic changes from whether it be a
lost or gained of specific gene apart or
their specific mutations or or even sort
of methylation changes that will be
affecting the genetic background so this
really outlines the connection between
the genetics of cancer and what's
observed in terms of the histopathology
one of the first important genes that
was discovered through the work of them
or full listing in another's was the
discovery of p53 sequencing many human
cancers in finding a sort of a loss of
the t3 and defining for the first time
p53 is a tumor suppressor gene and
laying the foundation for for cancer
genomics subsequent genes have been
found such as a PC which is shown here
or in terms of looking at an EGFR and
Cleo mas so this really sort of started
a whole revolution of finding genes that
were genetically altered that were has
later been really important I mean I'm
not understanding of cancer so
subsequent to that looking at besides
actually single genes there was looking
at larger families of genes specifically
and the Super Show is the tyrosine kinda
which is the comfortable complement of
tyrosine kinase and colorectal cancers
and this published in 2003 finding that
there were a large number of terracing
kinases that were mutated and I high
frequencies and colorectal cancers
subsequently similar work was able to
discover pik3ca as a novel oncogene for
cancer probably finding the gene but
also finding significant hotspots and
that the forest pik pca now it is a gene
of significant clinical interest be able
to develop there
you explore it and not only looking at
tyrosine kinase is similarly looking at
parenting phosphatases is another sort
of paper that was published subsequently
2004 in science looking at these sort of
gene families and cancer so ultimately
this laid the foundation that was
specifically looking at the genetics of
cancer and that being very important and
starting out by single genes are looking
at gene families and of course we know
there's a big change I mean in around
two thousand to one to them three and
subsequently with the finishing of the
human genome for the first time now we
can not only look at single genes with
GG families but the entire complement of
gene whether it be too XO more the
genome for cancer so some of the first
excellent studies was done at Johns
Hopkins apart our work there when I was
a graduate student there looking at the
full complement of genes there and this
is sort of prior to implementation of
next-generation sequencing technologies
so some of the early studies that were
done there I'm using mostly source and
technologies was be able to look at
first of all the the consensus coding
sequence of assisi BSG notes or 20,000
genes for breast and colorectal cancer
sequencing all their axons and be able
to find the mutation of profile for
cancers for the first time versus
initially published in 2007 looking at
it and finding that informally that the
mutation of profile of cancers was not
specifically to one gene family but it
actually was an entire landscape of it
subs come what we were able to actually
formalize this and later that year to
map it out shown in the picture here
that if you take a look at the landscape
which is shown if you take the
chromosome lining end-to-end from
chromosome 1 all the way to the phones
123 on the height of the landscape being
the mutational profile of these cancers
that there are some cancers are mutated
some jeans are make it at high frequency
which are normal no well known
cancer uncle genes are doing suppressor
gene but a lot of these smaller genes
are mutated smaller frequencies killed I
also are important in the landscape so
for the first time knowing not only that
there are these important genes mutated
high frequencies but also these sort of
lesser players but also contributing
significantly to cancer but really
showing that the complexity of cancer
and really sort of launching the field
of cancer genomics and Adsense sucks
social studies was done for pancreatic
cancer and not only looking them no
longer as single genes but be able to
group those genes as pathways so even
though that's specific Toomer's could
have different genes are mutated but
they share common pathways between the
different tumors so that for pancreatic
cancer we wave will identify
approximately 12 pathways in which even
the different tumors although they have
different individual genes are mutated
at different pathways but they share the
common pathways between the difference
between the different specific tumors
subsequently a at the same time we also
be able to perform the genomic analysis
for for brain cancer specifically for
GBM and we're able to discover an e very
important new gene specifically idh1
which is shown I mean the figure here of
well-known metabolic gene that mutated a
very high frequency and actually
clustered around a very significant
active site what was important about
this not only was it able to shown to
repeat it at high frequency actually
define a specific subtype of cancers
people are people with Leo Mazzone idh1
actually perform and have a better
prognosis than those who do not not
because that not specific mutation but
that this defines a new subtype of Leo
mazai at sort of idh1 mutations and
currently there are many people working
on specific therapeutic space on idh1
and even within the last few weeks there
have been
promising results have been reported in
mice using idh1 inhibitors to be able to
share effectiveness and trading
glioblastoma so with all these sort of
initial findings in cancer genomics
starting from single genes like you
mentioned families and eventually
looking at a genome wine in terms of X
own this really then allows us to start
thinking about how do we implement this
I'm a clinical scale and and be able to
really impact patients know in that way
and this is some of this work was done
by colleagues and I are Washington
University in st. Louis work and we were
starting to take some of these initial
research findings that that was done in
the research department and start
thinking about how to implement this on
clinical environment so done in a new
space specifically dedicated that is
within the pathology department on how
to implement not only sort of cancer
genomics but doing it in a clinical
context so the most important thing is
this wasn't done within a vacuum but
then it was important that it was a part
of already existing sort of pathology
services I had a really rich in terms of
faculty or 150 faculty and informatics
background with a significant research
background and combining a technology
expertise informatics expertise and
pathology expertise to be able to bring
this for and importantly to be able to
understand this how it's different to do
it within a clinical context versus in a
research context so so this is and sort
of the difference is actually
significant and barriers with a
non-trivial how how clinical sequencing
is different from research sequencing so
one of the first things we thought is we
actually designed a gene panel on to be
able to do we also later did it XO and
then how do you select the jeans if you
want to design your own
panel and for us I washy we had sort of
four criteria instead of just sort of
sequencing and tens of thousands of
genes we wanted to choose the genes that
were of clinical importance so the first
criteria was clinically actionable so if
you were sequencing jeans and you know
if the results that you see you can sort
of act upon it it is hard for it to be a
true sort of clinical tests so clinical
actionability was a little very
important factor in terms of the design
secondly is is it could um it may not
have a specific drug sort of tied to it
but it also could be Park not
necessarily relevant in terms of
important in terms of deciding whether
it was just gonna the course of the
patient whether you want to treat more
aggressively or not so that was it also
30-point the third aspect was you know
in terms of reimbursable this is very
sort of practical aspect as we design a
clinical tests that the payers will be
able to reimburse it so often these
would be genes that are already
reimbursed through Sanger sequencing and
this is we would be using a different
modality to be able to use it to be able
to sort of test for these genes so this
required a lot of sort of conversations
with payers to be able to determine you
know what genes will be reimbursable I
think with larger panel with a lot of
these genes are more sore loser level it
makes it harder to be reimbursable as a
clinical test it could be useful a sort
of as a clinical study for truly
reimbursable clinical tests on the
curation of these genes was highly
important and the last ex work was um
was a gene said then that the physicians
clinically already used it so because
these are the people that would be
ordering these tests it was important
for them to I'm have the gene panels
that they already understand because
they education part was going to be very
significant so including genes that they
already understand what's banana it is
very very important as we sort of design
these panels for them so that when they
look at the panel they already include
the genes that they normally use in
addition
of jeans that they potentially look or
consider consider adding on to the panel
so these were sort of four very
significant aspects in terms of thinking
about the design so of the specific
genes that we initially started of there
were sort of compliment around 30 genes
that we looked at and then included both
importance for solid tumors as well as
hematologic tumors as well as you can
see here and some of them are for both
and as you can see here in idh1 iht or
genes that we helped discover we're also
part of this panel and of great
importance there's some that are sort of
highlighted in bold that have specific
targeted therapy with it no for example
or higher importance suggests an emt are
known for alone and different targeting
cancers so this was really the gene set
that we use for that to be able to and
in terms of our curation of that initial
set in terms of the workflow we sure
here quickly oh the standard workflow is
very similar so from from steps of 128
here is shown in this diagram it's very
it's very much shared between sista
standard research work flow and the
clinical workflow so whether it's a
fragmentation DNA preparing the library
enriching and then you know doing the
standard problematics of a alignment and
bam files is all the same between
research as well as clinical but what
was very different than is from from
steps 9 10 11 so step 9 was very very
important terms with sort of the tier 2
informatics specifically you know in a
research context if you if you sequence
and have a result we can just report the
result write in and paper and it's done
but when within a clinical context these
results are acted upon so high
confidence about this results was going
to be very very important and this
confidence of the result is it not only
done on a gene level but it has to be
done on a mutation a mutation level so
so here for us we in order to build
be able to interpret this there was a
very lot of work done to build a
clinical grade database to be able to
curate for an hour every single gene
that's in that panel but also very
single position in the panel so that
every of these positions as we generate
these reports that the competence is not
done on a gene level but on them on a
mutation by mutation Louisville and
there's different levels of confidence
you want to build for this for example
the highest level competence of course
if you have evidence of that specific
tumor type in a specific gene in a
specific position with human clinical
data on to poor that's of the highest
confidence and that and that level sort
of it you know the highest level
confidence we would report out however
you know no not only patients for all
tumor types at that level complex so the
second level of confidence will be then
if you have a specific mutation of that
gene of in that position but not
necessarily about two more types for
example you have an EGFR mutation not
not specifically and long and the
different tumor type and and and that
could be a different interpretation a
third level of evidence at that can be
represented is is it mom it's in again
it's it it's shown in that gene in that
position and potentially you in that
tumor type or not but it's not specific
human clinical data so whether it's an
in vivo model or a vitro model those are
sort of more experimental models and new
minister at clinical and that's throw a
level about evidence down and you can
sort of surmise in terms of the
different levels evidence as we go down
is no not necessary level four would be
not necessarily a human but in in animal
models which is shown and in level five
and further down would be not even in
animal models but but in sort of bio
informatics in silikal prediction models
so this level of informatics is is
really a huge huge difference between
what you what one does in a research
context versus it's done in a clinical
context
septum is also very significantly
different in terms of clinical genomics
versus just research genomics is is that
you know there's a clinician that
ultimately signs out often for us is we
have a specific pathologist who
understands not only the biology and
medical aspects but also the informatics
and research aspects that's able to take
all the information that we're able to
convey from our databases from from the
raw data and it'd be able to then craft
a report to be able to do that and and
this is not a significant in significant
step it often takes many many hours to
go through all the literature and to be
able to sort of create the best curate
all the best evidence and be able to
sign up the case so it could be helpful
for oncologist and finally step number
11 then the report for the oncologist
would be one thats able to summarize all
the data and one that it's
understandable form oncologists without
significant so the training would even
understanding NGS that they can be able
to so that the average oncologist would
be able to understand this data and
potentially you know for example point
to existing clinical trials point you to
target the therapies that might be
helpful in these aspects and really
providing all the odd facts it's going
to be helpful in clinical decision
making so some of the sort of the
technical challenges we want to think
about and clinical context versus
research concerts are Fe I list some
here for example and I'm working whether
with ffpe or frozen samples per sister
of tissue lines in a research context
I'm often another is the amount of
specimen that you have it very small
what if I biopsy or psychology so that's
something we be able to do we r 3 is you
know be able to take variants as low as
20 percent is the tumor celerity may not
be able to contain you know from your
specimen have have hi to Michelle there
so the verification in this context
would be very important microdissection
sometimes not necessarily is beneficial
but be able to do that because microsite
play section takes significant amounts
of time read death because of tumor
heterogeneity we
look at between 500 and a thousand fold
and then often in order to reduce costs
as significance with multiplexing and I
think as previous said that the the
reform must be simplified so that it is
not one that's needed for sort of
next-generation sequencing experience
before the average oncologist and in the
clinical grade database it's going to be
important in terms of the difference
between a clinic clinical sequencing
versus on research sequencing so this is
a graph of our sort of sensitivity in
terms of be able to detect our in terms
of ten percent and you can see here
shown and the black is sensitivity and
the red is a positive predictive value
so as you can see on the x axis is the
coverage and the y axis is percentage
then there's a really little quick
increase in terms of as in terms of
sensitivity in the early with coverage
but there's an inflection point probably
around a sort of a thousand x where
you're able to detect about sort of
ninety percent frequency percentage and
sort of ten percent that they'll
frequency and this is going to be
important because of heterogeneity in
tumors or this aspect and finally this
is a sort of the list of our of the
genes that we use in our sort of smaller
panel and combination we use in terms of
fish and sang as well as NGS and then
the different tumors edits in different
tumors obviously have indications of
which of the the genes that will be more
helpful but because of costs associated
sometimes just as cost-effective issues
will do the whole panel but for example
the specific targeted therapies are two
specific tissue types when those will be
important so whether it's all tumors or
liquid tumors the specific genes would
be important for those aspects and this
is shown here so the oncologist has the
flexibility of ordering just for example
the email panel or the lung panel the
melanoma panel or the option of ordering
the entire panel for the purposes
so this is sort of for a first time
really i think we're excited and that
that patients are being helped on a
daily basis not only from from the
research accidents / from a clinical
aspect from as long so for first sort of
the next half is we're going to
specifically talk about what are some
lessons then that can be sort of taken
Oh from from our research aspects first
of all in terms of thinking about
participants election so you see here on
the x-axis is whether the decision
making is done on a group were on
individual level and then on the y-axis
whether it's done a clinical versus
research and the traditional is it
starting from the quadrant on the bottom
bottom left where I mean research
context a group makes a decision and
understand in research context but
ultimately then the movement is is to
establishing little clinical text that
is in the top right corner where an
individual is able to make your decision
and it's done in the clinical context so
to to specific sort of challenges must
be done is first of all criteria
development to be able to move from a
group decision to individual decision
aspect um and so who are the people
you're going to be ordering this test on
whether it's know people refractory
cancer or what you can even would you be
able to order this tester as you're
putting on pretty early on so this
criteria memilih is able to then no
longer Google I on a group to be able to
have done an individual from moving from
research to clinical then is it salute
or shown here in sort of clinical test
development where you know establishing
me up for example the clinical grade
database having clinicians be able to
sign up which it reports creation of the
report as little clinically interpretive
all is going to be important so
ultimately starting from the bottom from
from the bottom left moving from the top
right it is sort of the implement in
patient of our test
in terms of the study design terms of
the coverage a lot of people sort of
talked about you know in terms of the
number of genes that one should do which
is sort of shown here on the x axis
versus whether the depth of coverage at
you get obviously with a finite number
of reads there's sort of a trade-off
between breath versus depth and
traditionally if you look at the far
left by single gene Sanger you're able
to sort of sequence at a very high high
depth so so the trade-off here then is
whether one does sort of a gene panel
which is X 0 vs genome for for cancer so
for us we think because oh so what data
shown earlier that the coverage because
of tumor heterogeneity we wanted to fix
up mutations at a ten percent would
require actually very significant
college o.o potentially even know
thousand x500 to the thousand x so shown
here in purple is sort of a gene panel
of cancer this allows you and to be able
to sort of catch the genes at our hetero
g the heterogeneity of these cancers
even at low amounts however you know you
can know people obviously haven't been
able to create no test in terms of 00 x
own but the coverage definitely will not
be a significant so you will be able you
will miss be able to sort of coverage in
terms of the heterogeneity and that
aspect there and ultimately people also
be able to work out whole genome but for
cancer really it's hard unless you're
able to significantly no not think about
the heterogeneity so whether and you
have a lot of the specific specimen or
whether you're able to sort of grow that
specimen in terms of a cell line to be
able to do that but but in terms of our
understanding and working with patients
we really think that as a gene panel not
even a large chain panel a smaller gene
panel that's highly curated it's highly
actionable that's that's highly
informative and and be able to cover
that at depth is is potentially sort of
a better approach
the one that you know he wanted to sort
of significant number of genes of which
of the findings you find you don't know
what to do with so that's a big
difference between for the clinical
research and then we would think then
you know if the if the gene panel is
negative then there people are
interested in doing more deeper sort of
analysis then the whole axle approach
can be done understanding that of course
the covered will be less and not
covering in terms of the heterogeneity
in terms of the sample prep in terms of
how to be able to sort of in bridge for
these areas of course there are sort of
two main aspects that people do whether
you want to do the amplicon approach
there's an enrichment versus the capture
approach the benefits of this weather
amplicon approaches use is is that we
can be very sort of specific in terms of
what you want to amplify out to turn
because of your primers is kind and and
it's done in the panel which is shown
here whether it's ample see or using
fluid I'm the raindance systems for
panels or you can use capture system the
capture system is you know you're able
to do a lot more often and Exum approach
where captured I really has been a
dominant approach here whether it would
nimblegen or to see or agilent or with
with smaller panels at different
institutions be able to see so whether
you know I just list some examples here
that are able to build their own panels
and capture the benefit of this is
actually it's pretty you know simple to
sort of design and capture panel clear
that the down the downside of sort of
amplicon systems is if you will use the
information from copy number from that
if that's something of interest there
because of you know different
amplification so you would lose that
information so that would allow us no
really think that capture methods are a
better for the method there it's a
sample prep in terms of the technology I
think you know we've seen them to come
and go of many different second
generation technologies and whether
whether it be you know celexa and I've
been alumina or or life or know
initially purchasing ABI and I
torn and hope that she would you know
and then technology that no longer you
know as popular whether its helical for
450 original or Complete Genomics but
obviously everybody is looking towards
third generation technologies you know
obviously most excited with people with
Astra nanopore and with the news is you
know the new bio announcing their system
or whether an abscess but the importance
is here is as we talk about clinical
sequencing the important aspect actually
is does not lie within the technology
the important as I actually lies with
the annotation lies in the gene curation
lies with the love of evidence you
provide their lies with the personnel
that you use to be able to sort of sign
up these samples so that even if these
different technologies are rolled online
what's important in terms of clinical
aspect is that database that's used for
annotation for that so so I mean third
generation will be able to obviously
reduce and cost may be able to
potentially be able to look at
heterogeneity better but but
interpretation systems ultimately still
is going to be most important attention
at that bioinformatics so since we're
talking about informatics you know
there's a sort of rough outline whether
from the reads that you came from the
machine he started sort of doing
alignment doing variant calling
alignment we know most people for the
PWA or bowtie or soap and a beer and
calling in a gk Sam fools and then be
able to then filter based on what you
know so there's a movement whether
people sort of do it in terms of locally
or cloud there and then I think and
people have sort of different options
here it seems like a lot of people now
have been able to sort of do most of the
line of variant calling and their local
aspect which is shown in the orange and
then some was because the annotation is
sort of built in a cloud with ago in a
queen so shown in the orange and green
is often implemented many systems be
able to leverage annotation has done in
the cloud however you know they are no
systems were
you know that people are able to do
alignment variant calling in the cloud
but because of large file sizes to be
able to do that actually much much
easier do that locally and then you see
the purple here then you know there's
people solutions be able to then do not
only that line miracle also vana tation
locally or in the call as a system but
it but then we rely on a clinical
reporting from form of the third source
and ultimately shown here at the very
end is whether there's you know the
whole system done locally in the cloud
so ultimately clinical informatika
little genomics and for cancer can be
done either in really a sort of a
distributed system where everybody has
their own my siguen torn and able to do
everything locally and do that or or you
can think about where it could be a
centralized system in all such that one
that you know complete genomics was
hoping to point out that you know it's
done all at a large side where samples
are sent so this is still to be yet
determined whether no clinical cancer
genomics will be done in a distributed
manner from our local labs or running
sort of PGMs of my cigs or whether we
done a large genome center is like you
know like the guerrilla PGI and in that
context and this is you know political
precedence for example in the US
clinical testing whether done by big
companies like west or labcorp or
whether in a local test in hospitals as
well so so both are models that are
considered and the informatics follows
that very closely and lastly you know as
you think about informatics you know how
to then you know interpret it not only
in terms of matching known variants but
looking at population frequencies
looking at known annotations looking at
the genetics but also using in a
prediction algorithms whether it be ones
are very well known like sift and
polyphen or many of the ones that are
coming out there are able to take into
consideration no homology modeling 3d
structure functional annotation as such
to be able to do that or filtering
and in terms of the reporting this is a
very very containable area of active
discussion is what you then poured it
back out to the patient and and I show
here quickly you know in a simplified
matter or potentially there are two axes
going from on the x-axis from a closed
you don't so that you don't reveal
anything that patients to an open
platform can tell everything in and on
the y-axis from research to clinical so
traditionally has been done sort of a
closed research system which is shown in
the bottom left quadrant and then as
more and more sequencing is done you
know there's discussion of reporting of
incidental findings and how that is
important as a movement of more due to
the top right quadrant where it's done
on a clinical aspect and a more open
basis and I here I shows should show
some examples the most extreme here
obviously being the Personal Genome
Project where or individual variables
will publish their genomes online after
going through very very rigorous consent
procedures but the the movement here
within the field is is going to be more
and more open of course they're going to
do a requiring a lot of sort of public
education to be able to sort of give all
that data back on whether the exome data
whether it be specific gene panels but
that's sort of the movement you can see
here as research clinical from closed to
open and then I think ultimately I think
about other sort of specific testing
that we really really shouldn't think
about what people call sort of genetic
exceptionalism where we think genetic
data is different from any other
clinical data we need to protect
patients from it but the more you know
we can give them access we know whether
people are having the whole genome
sequence when they're born and then be
able to then be able to reference as
they use it they like and reimbursement
often is also very key as well and I
show this in terms of as a rough and as
shown in a large scale in terms of cost
and NGS sequencing shown here as a
second
bar here whether it's 4x on Gino between
sort of the one thousand to ten thousand
dollar logo but which is very actually
consider no in the same range as whether
it's bracha testing or scale gene
testing and so in terms of cost
effectiveness is there as similar there
and and that will obviously continue to
drop which is very comparable obviously
to to MRI CT scan endoscopy or or to the
extent a hospital stay so I've been
looking reimbursement and as the prices
drop this is not going to be a
significant aspect if it's going to be
justified in terms of clinical decision
making so at the end here it's important
to say that you know whether it be you
know panels or genomes or exomes these
are these are not of perfect systems so
I'm going to sort of walk through some
of the caveats that you want to think
number one is insufficient power
annotation I think we talked about the
clinical database but most of the
variants that you'll be able to discover
potentially are are of unknown
significance so that's going to be
important secondly even if you do XO
there's no why you know people discuss
about so the first exon drop off in
terms of hi GC coverage and the coverage
is going to be a big ass placate
especially with larger panels that even
if you cover in a ninety percent that's
a significant amount of jeans and
excellence you're not covering so it's
important to differentiate lack of
coverage of versus not finding it a gene
in that aspect not so that first exon
problem it continues to be one of great
significance next I think that the
interests of the informatics will the
field is better at looking at a single
need to cut variations but there's new
method now looking at copy number
alterations and translocations but that
still is sort of what in works we will
to do that in a rigorous manner so right
now most of the emphasis has been on
sort of me single implementations but as
technologies mature will be able to look
at all these different genetic
alterations as well
and even as we do this even if we do X
on the force we miss out on the introns
of micro RNA so just because we don't
sort of see it in our panels doesn't
mean it doesn't exist that's going to be
important and I think the bottom ones
are the tools are specific about sort of
been dealing diseases and this is real
less importance within sort of cancer
but they're they're going to be sort of
non-genetic non-mendelian tegra so
whether the second panel here thinking
about the genetics or microbiome a
specific or cancer you want to think
about whether you're looking at somatic
mutations were sequencing both the
cancer as well as normal or you're just
sequencing just a cancer and there's no
different pros and cons now obviously
you'll get better results by sequencing
both on the cancer as well as the normal
but again they're sort of cost
considerations and lastly you sort of in
terms of alignment and Aaron called
variant calling although the algorithms
are pretty mature in themselves but even
if you run very sort of well known
Edward there are very much differences
even if these differences are let's say
you know they're even if at 95
concordance rate between these different
algorithms that five percent if it's
right five percent that that you in a
clinical setting that guy is very very
significant if if I've out of 9500 your
patients have a long call that that's
going to be a very much a big problem
there so i think that the alignment
algorithms ovarian colon erica's as well
as the annotation databases we must
understand that they're not in a hundred
percent right now and using that in a
clinical context for weather for
position medicine weather for Taylor
therapy you need to think of it as well
and so that
just sort of in brief quickly in terms
of sort of our experience I'm looking at
cancer genomics and excitement is is how
all the research now is now being
translated and we're excited that that
patients are are going to meet specific
be help them so we're very there's
obviously a lot of people to help to
thank but these are just some of the
people that I really took the concert we
did there's artwork and then you have
any sort of questions this is sort of my
email and feel free to connect me up
there so good I saw a little bit of time
for questions and answers which i will
start taking it look at oh and for those
who want to get a continuing education
credits this is that what the link and
to get specific credits there I'm gonna
leave it on the emails for those so I'm
going to now answer some of the
questions so the first question we have
here is from University of Massachusetts
dr. van thinking about what is the best
biggest obstacle to demonstrating the
value proposition of molecular
diagnostics and increasing reimbursement
for these tests that is that is a great
great question in terms of what is the
clinical value so it's a couple things
and this is really built into how we
select our gene panel first of all you
need to show that it does affect
clinical clinical decision making so if
your panel really consists of genes were
even if you find a mutation it really
doesn't affect your care of the patients
that's not going to be you know very
convincing to payers so so it has to be
genes where for example you know like
egfr where there's no targeted therapies
where you know you can really make a
difference
and clinical decision making is going to
be very very important there in that
same sense actually of the the contrary
also is going to be important is that
there's not going to be stuff that's of
less sort of helpful to clinical
decision making meaning you know panels
with large numbers of genes of which
many of them do not know meet those
criteria then the pair's can just say
that this list looks much more like a
research panel because if you know most
of these genes even if you find a
mutation really want to be able to
affect the care so they're they're less
than possibilities for them to be able
to argue that this is not a clinical
tests but in terms of just more research
test so the demonstration of the value
really is for the clinical value and if
you are able to sort of show that you
know this really and changes how you
treat patients that is truly know the
ultra metric to be able to do that don't
see any other questions coming so we
people have questions later feel free to
email me if not I guess we'll be able to
then end this session early then thank
you very much for your time and
attending this conference and feel free
to email me if you have any questions
and thank you for by our conference and
a conference organizers and for putting
this together thank you